[Music]
hi there Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today we are going to take a
look at a different kind of atomic 3
beat weave but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling call
pyrro Tera light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy for helping them make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission all right
so clearly this is not the usual
perspective that you get of my home
studio but there there is a reason for
it namely um I've heard a bunch of
different ways to describe how to
perform Atomic weaves where you have
both of the POI in vertical planes that
is I've already done a tutorial on how
to do the vertical versus horizontal
plane Atomic weave but uh when it comes
to doing the vertical versus vertical
plane one it can be really really really
hard to see what exactly is going on if
you don't have a perspective on this
weave from above so today I'm going to
take you through it from this very odd
but very helpful perspective so there
are two individual Concepts that we are
playing with in talking about this move
atomics and weaves I'm going to go
through each of them individually here
now most of the time when we spend POI
we are doing so in such a way that we
have two planes that are running
parallel to each other or each of the
POI together in the same plane like so
but we also have the option of moving
the POI in playe that are at right
angles to each other hence atomics and
there's a bunch of different uses for
this idea from the aforementioned Atomic
weaves to things like doing diagonal
planes as you're going back and forth
with split time butterflies across your
body there's all sorts of ways that this
works but the particular way that we're
talking about in this video involves
doing a 3B weave but kind of playing
around with the way that the planes
operate in relation to each other so of
course we know the basic structure a 3B
weave we've played with this in past
videos and if you do not already have
this move under your belt I will go
ahead and link to a tutorial on it down
in the description but the long short of
it is this we are moving the the POI
back and forth in parallel planes to
each side of our body we have a cross
point that is basically sticking
directly out in front of us as we are
performing this weave and we are
performing it in such a way that each
hand does a total of three beats one two
beats on the non-native side and one on
the native one two beats on the
non-native side and one on the native
the way this usually breaks down of
course is we go over under back over
under back just like so okay so how do
we take that idea of a 3B weave and
apply it in such a way that we can get
the PO operating in slightly different
planes at the same time and bow them out
to create this really cool version of
the 3B weave where we're getting this
kind of right angle between the planes
here the first thing I want you to play
around with is going to involve just
shortening up the PO you want to wrap
them around your hands one time and then
take them into a buzz slw plane now from
here I want you to point the right hand
POI slightly off on a diagonal uh
imagine that it's either pointed off to
the corner of the room or it's pointed
back towards your left shoulder
whichever works best for you now the
left hand po you're going to likewise
bring out on a diagonal either thinking
that it's pointing to the corner of the
room or back at your right shoulder or
both and now we are in a position where
we have the two pois spinning in Split
Time same direction and the right hand
goes past the left shoulder and the left
hand poy goes past the right shoulder
and wouldn't you know it the buzz saw
still works it didn't stop working just
because we happen to stick our po planes
at a right angle all right so how
exactly are we going to translate this
idea from a buzz saw to a weave kind of
place I'm so glad you asked our first
step is going to be to take our body and
we're going to orient oriented about 45°
between our wall plane and our wheel
plane orientations here so we wind up
pointing over towards the corner and
from this orientation right here I want
you to get the right hand Poise spinning
by your side so it's on that diagonal
now this next part is going to be a
little bit of a challenge but you're
going to get the left hand point also
spinning on a diagonal but it's going to
be the opposite diagonal that is it's
going to look like it is spinning
counterclockwise relative to you and
this is going to mean that you're going
to try and have to keep your hands
separate from each other now as this is
happening I want you to take your right
hand and practice going back and forth
back and forth across over top of that
left hand like so the idea being that
we're kind of doing the same thing that
we would be doing in a TW beat weave but
in this particular case we are doing it
in atomic planes instead of in wheel
plane and of course we want to learn how
to do this same thing with our left hand
so we're going to take our upper body
and switch it over to Bing on a 45°
angle here we're going to get that left
hand Poise spinning forwards at our side
and we're going to get the right hand
pois spinning what looks like clockwise
relative to us to us right now the left
hand is going to cross over and then
back over and then back over and then
back again we got we kind of have to
keep our hands and Poise separate uh in
order to make make sure they don't run
into each other over here when they're
open but when we cross the left hand
over the right we should find that the
two po planes just mesh together in such
a way that we can bring our hands close
together which is part of the key to
getting the hole moved down all right so
let's see if we can put these two pieces
together so I'm going to go ahead and
cross my left hand over my right and
then come on over here to open back up
on my right hand side where I have my
right hand on the diagonal my left hand
looking like it is spinning
counterclockwise relative to me I'm
going to cross my right hand over boom
and open back up here on my left side
where it's going to feel like my left
hand PO is spinning forwards on that
diagonal and the right hand po looks
like it is spinning uh clockwise
relative to me so I go left over open
right over open left over open right
over open so if that feels relatively
comfortable our next move is to take out
those points where we are opening back
up our arms to either side so rather
than going over to the left and opening
up my left hand next to my right hand I
instead want to do this in such a way
that I'm always changing up which hand
is on top I think left hand on top right
hand on top left hand on top right hand
on top like so and this takes it back
into 3 beat weave territory and look at
that we're now getting those beautiful
diagonal planes too I really like this
pattern if for no other reason than
having the planes kind of spit lit out
at those right angles uh kind of opens
this up in such a way that from
different perspectives this can look
like both a 3B weave as well as a split
time butterfly both interpretations are
kind of valid here and of course you can
really trip this out by trying to draw
it to extreme sides of your body um we
just want to try and make sure that
we're keeping the Cross Point of our
right hand po pointed off to that corner
on our right and the Cross Point for the
left hand POI off in that corner off to
the left we can always make a visual
check whenever we turn our body and make
sure that we have the uh non-native hand
that is if I'm on my left side my right
hand and if I'm on my right side my left
hand spinning in such a way that it
looks like it is in wall plane relative
to us and the other poy is in wheel
plane like so we don't get a lot of call
for Atomic weaves anymore these days and
I think that that's kind of a shame
because this eats up a lot of volume and
space around us in ways that a lot of
poy tricks don't but hey by putting out
videos like this it might mean more
people try it cool so did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it and of
course to help my channel
[Music]
grow hey thanks so much for watching
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I want to shout out my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now uh if you'd like to check out more
videos that I have done of atomic weaves
and other uh 3D po tricks I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
and also too if you would like to
support the channel I will include a
link to my patreon down there as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
out and flow today and I'll see you with
a new video real soon peace